I use the word hipster in my book and
use it just in conversation sort of
reluctantly because it sounds like an
insult and I don't mean it as an insult
um and I'm also when I you know talking
about hipsters I'm not talking about you
know some extreme group of you know
ultra Trinity people holed up somewhere
in Williamsburg or red hook or you know
I'm not talking about some really
smaller elite group of people to me I
use the word to describe this kind of
national or even international consensus
that exists among city dwellers of a
certain age and of a certain kind of
cultural disposition um you know people
who listen to indie rock and people who
dress in sort of somewhat similar ways
the and to me as you say what's
remarkable is how steady that kind of
cultural cohort has been in their taste
and in the in the kind of uniformity of
their taste and also just how
undifferentiated it is from place to
place to place I mean you sort of talk
about going to williamsburg after four
years and feeling like everything's the
same well what I find remarkable is that
you know you go and see people in San
Francisco or you see them in Chicago you
see them in Boston all around the
country if you go and see your friends
who were part of the same rough
demographic you'll find that um that
they're all listening to the same bands
and they're reading similar books
they're um they're interested in the
same kind of culture and to me this is
just one of the products of the internet
it you know it's that the fact that um
that the Internet has allowed people to
find culture instantaneously and
simultaneously the fact that the
Internet has also allowed you know
geography not to become too much of a
factor in terms of what music you're
listening to or what newspaper you're
reading I mean you know people people in
San Francisco are is apt to read the New
York Times Online as people in New York
are and so you find that people are are
able to access
same sort of stuff and so on so to me
the you know when I talk about hipster
culture to me it's this kind of
fascinating National Urban middlebrow um
and that it has remained remarkably
stable in terms of how people dress and
what people are into and that it is um
you know it's it's it's the it's the way
to be a kind of upwardly mobile urban
sort of twenty and thirtysomething in
America today I've heard other people
used the expression India p instead of
hipster and that maybe as a more apps
expression in that it gets set at the
kind of uniformity of this culture
across the country
to me what's replaced differentiators
based on where you are or
differentiators based on different sort
of camps or schools you know um I think
that you know kind of young it's sort of
intellectual culture or young sort of
cultural fans used to break down in
terms of you know in terms of camps um
or in terms of there would be
geographical divisions to meet today
what's replaced all that is speed um you
that there's more churn there's more of
a scent art of the reason why um there
can be this uniformity and there can be
this kind of sense of of stasis that can
last over essentially a whole decade is
that um is that there are constantly new
cultural products that are being thrown
at people again because of the internet
you know and this is this is one of the
main thesis of my book is that um you
know what the internet kind of culture
does to us is it throws this barrage of
novelty whether it's new bands or its
new books or it's you know some new
political arguments or some new tiny
little celebrity you know that that
we're constantly being subject to these
waves and waves of these these news
stories and that that because of that we
feel like we are living in this very
dynamic way we feel like we're living in
this very dynamic time and yet um so
much of what's being thrown at us is
forgettable it's disposable a lot of it
is stuff that we look back on at you
know even just a few weeks after we find
out about it and we sort of think oh
that's not really very interesting
anymore but of course we don't look back
on it because we're on to the next thing
and so you know that to me is the UM is
the kind of paradox in the problem of
culture making today as a whole is that
is that the speed and the turn of the
internet culture or the sort of culture
that the internet enables allows us to
feel like that there's something going
on when in fact a lot of times there's
there's not that
much interesting going on